how many times do you feel unmotivated
or you feel like you wake up and just i
don't feel like doing anything today or
you feel lost or maybe you feel like
what am i doing this far so you know
that one video
that says
he says
you know you wake up in the morning and
you say
i still go to the gym because i don't
feel like it we're not the same i feel
like working out every day you know i
don't know if you've seen that one the
audio that goes that's picked up on tick
tock i'm not probably not saying it the
right way but here's the point uh i
think that's
a great video to go viral i don't think
that's the reality because there's going
to be many days i don't feel like being
a dad because of the responsibilities of
changing the diaper and i got poop on my
jacket one day i'm having a business
meeting and i'm holding my son i have my
brand new lakers gear that i'm wearing
all of a sudden i'm looking at the guys
i'm like why do you guys did you guys
step into something i said look at the
bottom of your shoes they're looking no
pat we didn't step in why why does this
place smell so bad
so then all of a sudden like hey pat can
you look at your son i look at my son no
joke
everywhere here no no i'm trying to
encourage you from not having kids
you see in that moment i'm not feeling
like being a dad yeah yeah
i wish it was in a different place right
you don't feel like running a
media company when this thing keeps
breaking the audio is not being picked
up there's noise in the background and
chips are getting lost and the 30
minutes has gone and you lost best
footage that would have done very well
you don't feel good in that moment so
but the reality of it is you know in
those moments if you truly have a vision
that's a real vision it's a big vision
and it excites you so much
you have no choice but have to tolerate
chaos
in times of stress and things not going
your way you don't have a choice so when
in that moment some people are like i
just don't feel like doing it today no
problem it's your choice
but if your vision's big you kind of got
to figure out a way to win on days that
you don't feel like it yeah now and you
were mentioning though in like 2007-2008
you
rethought how you want to go about
business and things you want to do how
did you go about doing that was it was
there a strategy that you used or how
did you think of the next big thing when
you didn't know it yet so when i didn't
know it yet well i didn't know the
bigger vision is what i didn't know
right so for me i got 20 different
motivators under four different
categories that people have one is
individual so you have individual
accomplishments you're going after right
you want to have a degree to be able to
say you went to ucla or you went to penn
you went to wharton that's an individual
accomplishment makes you proud right
individual you want to have a car a
watch close you know house whatever
right that's individual accomplishments
those will run out eventually if it's
just individual then you have one that's
lifestyle lifestyle is purely selfish
stuff that you want the other one is a
purpose you know i want to do something
big and memorable and the last one is
madness madness is
you know
michael jordan is part of madness
community tom brady is part of madness
community connor is part of madness
community i mean you can go down a bunch
of people you know that are part of
madness community you'll know if you're
part of madness community or you're not
part of madness community i read i read
two books one was called hypomanic edge
and the other one was called first rate
madness why you know some titles like
why the crazy people run the world today
you know whatever it says about people's
personality disorders so for me in oh
wait
i'm so upset because i finally figured
out that money doesn't drive me
it's got to be something more than money
it's got to be something that's a vision
a correcting and injustice
you know that's my belly there's fire in
my belly constantly i can't get rid of
it i've tried a lot because believe me
life would be probably a lot more
peaceful without it because you can take
time outs and kind of be a little bit
more but you have to be self-aware and
know who you are right so for me i sat
there and i said okay so what are we
doing
is it the big parties is it the house
what is it no it's not it's much bigger
than that okay how does this feel you
know sometimes you want to buy that
watch let's just say you know the
beautiful watch you have there and let's
just say you go look at it first time
and he said babe i like this watch how
much is it babe
68 000
okay
not gonna buy it right now i'm gonna go
and see if i still like it you come back
you look at it again
i still like it you come back two months
later
it doesn't do it for me anymore why buy
it
okay but if you keep seeing something
and it keeps drawing you in maybe
there's something you got to pay
attention to there right so for me what
a cause was
every time i like you know people say
why do you talk politics you were doing
great with valuetainment you talking
entrepreneurship why touch politics you
shouldn't do it you don't do it gary
doesn't do it a lot of you guys don't do
it you guys are just kind of like yeah
your business saying like
i'll have you do it man i'll listen to
you yeah
i don't want to take the risk let this
guy do it he's losing followership
because they don't like the fact that
he's given his opinions
and i can take that strategy right and
by the way i know that you guys know i
know that you guys know that why is this
guy touching politics because we know
the space but at the same time
i can't help myself because it's so deep
in my bones
that for me it's more than having 100
million subscribers or 50 million
subscribers we got to have that not
because it's bragging rights we got to
have that because we get to get to more
eyeballs to get the message across right
so the messaging for me changed a little
bit but i i got more and more self-aware
and 08 of myself than i was in o2 in o2
i was just
just wanting to make money i hated being
broke it was a completely different
perspective 08 was like okay you can
actually compete in a marketplace and
you can actually make some real money
but what's bigger than that so that was
the shift that i made got it can you say
about how much you had
when you realized that you didn't want
to focus half a million dollars savings
it's not a lot of money but for me it
was a lot of money that i had in 08. if
you enjoyed this video i give a keynote
a few weeks ago in las vegas
specifically on the topic of cracking a
code to content creation if you've not
seen it click here to watch it take care
everybody bye
[Music]